tras muchas advertencias es oficial el
Tribunal Superior electoral de Brasil
implementarán medidas para intentar
controlar la desinformación y las
noticias falsas en la recta final de las
elecciones en la feroz campaña entre
Yair bolsonaro y Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva
todo el mundo ha estado viendo que desde
el inicio de la segunda vuelta hubo un
aumento una proliferación no solo de
noticias falsas sino también de la
agresividad de estas noticias y el
discurso de odio
ahora las plataformas de internet queden
difusión a la campaña sucia y no retiren
el contenido en un Rango de dos horas se
enfrentan a multas de hasta 19.000
dólares el tc ya ha ordenado que se
retiren algunos vídeos que difunden
desinformación como los que aseguran que
Lula es un Aliado de Satanás o los que
acusan a bolsonaro de ser caníbal temas
que han fomentado ataques cruzados entre
los mismos candidatos
eres el rey de las fake news y de la
estupidez de mentir la sociedad
brasileña usted mintió sobre la vacuna
todo el tiempo descuidó el tema de la
vacuna
si no mintieras no serías tú me llamas
genocida miliciana y caníbal todo el
tiempo
con la escalada de la atención y de la
circulación de fake news la autoridad
electoral ella advirtió de la necesidad
de eliminar con más rapidez en la
desinformación no obstante algunos han
criticado la medida por el poco tiempo
que tienen las plataformas para retirar
los contenidos y también por el poder de
censura que otorga el presidente del
tribunal cuyo criterio será determinante
para emitir las órdenes judiciales